[Music]
many mcu fans are eagerly awaiting the
upcoming spider-man no way home it can
be assumed that the multiverse which was
opened up in the loki series will really
take the spotlight in what will probably
be tom holland's last mcu appearance but
in 2022 we can also look forward to
several mcu hits after doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness is
scheduled for release in march taika
waititi's 4 love and thunder will be
released in may currently the latter is
still in the middle of filming which was
recently snapped by the british tabloid
daily mail the unofficial pictures
mainly feature christian bale in his new
role as gore the god butcher having not
been spotted with his outfit before
bale's appearance makes the shots all
the more interesting in fact gore's
looks and the comics aren't really
exciting he's just a grey-skinned alien
with a black cape including a cowl the
set photos do indeed show bale in his
silver grey outfit though many fans
complain that he looks more like a greek
stature than a fearsome villain although
these malicious tongues are not
completely wrong it can be assumed that
gore will be given a proper makeover in
the digital post-production thor love
and thunder will be released next year
on may 6th
what seemed almost impossible three
years ago turned into reality this year
the long-awaited snyder cut of justice
league by director zack snyder was
finally released after the movie also
received much better reviews than the
2017 cut the question of a sequel
naturally arises a recent interview with
producer charles roven to the hollywood
reporter could provide us with some
insight indeed rovan explained that
there is an agreement with warner
brothers which specifies that the
producer and his team must handle a
certain number of films especially those
related to man of steel the same applies
to new batman suicide squad or even
justice league films the reason for this
is that a producer is meant to remain
committed to a certain movie category
which is obviously not that easy in a
complex universe full of superheroes and
villains rowan himself is currently
working on other suicide squad movies
and estimates that he won't be working
on justice league 2 in the coming few
years should one be released at some
point however it is considered
guaranteed that rovan will be part of it
again it should be exciting to see how
the dc extended universe will develop in
the meantime an essential part of this
will be dc's major project the flash
which follows justice league in terms of
content and will be released on november
4th 2022
since its release in 2016 the netflix
series strange of things has not only
brought worldwide fame to a few
teenagers overnight but it has also
given the streaming provider one of the
most successful in-house productions in
the company's history the excitement for
the mystery series hasn't worn off to
this day which is why millions of fans
are still eagerly awaiting the release
of season 4. their patience is beginning
to wear thin and for good reason after
all the last season was released more
than two years ago already all the more
pleasing it is that netflix has now
shown mercy and published a few images
as well as a sneak peek in the teaser
you can get an exciting glimpse of the
upcoming season even though a release
this year is unfortunately out of the
question as you can see in the clip a
release is currently scheduled for the
coming year we will therefore have to
remain patient a little bit longer in
addition to visual highlights there is
also some more news regarding the future
of the netflix series series creator
sean levy told collider that the end of
the series is definitely imminent and
that the series finale is already being
considered in plain english this likely
means that season 4 will be followed by
a fifth and final season afterwards
there are various possibilities for
spin-offs that could significantly
expand the stranger things universe with
a serious huge popularity it is quite
possible that we'll have a much bigger
stranger things franchise in a few years
so what spin-offs would you like to see
or do you even believe a movie could be
just as successful feel free to drop a
comment down below
the future of the popular deadpool
franchise under disney's management has
long been in doubt all the more pleasing
it is now that there were actually first
progress reports from leading actor ryan
reynolds as part of a promotional tour
for his upcoming film free guide he gave
an interview to the us magazine collider
there he answered quite candidly the
questions about the current status of
the script as well as the expected start
of shooting according to his own
statement the likelihood of a filming
star in the upcoming year is about 70
percent in addition the 44 year old
announced that the script is at present
in a very active development phase and
that his co-writers are extremely smart
and talented the talk is of the two
sisters wendy molyneux and lizzie
mulliner laglan who are also in charge
of the animated series bob's burgers for
example this also makes it clear that
the authors of the previous movie red
reese and paul roernick are no longer
involved in the project it is therefore
apparent that for whatever reason
crucial personal changes have already
been made under disney's direction
according to kevin feige and ryan
reynolds however the r rating which is
so important for the film series is not
at risk reynolds himself could even
imagine making an appearance in another
movie from the mcu alongside deadpool 3.
he is said to be receptive to the idea
of disney bringing in his character in a
lot of crazy ways we are definitely
excited and look forward to more news
concerning deadpool 3.
in 2016 the netflix series lucifer was
released and now after the sixth and
final season it will come to an end fans
are naturally wondering will the duo of
lucifer and chloe be able to save the
world from doom a first trailer for the
season which will be available in about
a month provides answers to at least
some questions and gives us first
impressions of new characters especially
striking is the appearance of deadpool
star bryanna hildebrand who takes on the
role of the rebellious angel and
antagonist rory likewise noteworthy is
the teaser for some sort of animated
episode as well as the surprising return
of kevin alejandro as then how exactly
he has returned to the realm of living
is something we will soon find out as
lucifer season 6 will premiere in the us
on netflix on september 10th 2021
already
it has been known for some time that
sonic's later sidekick knuckles will
appear in the sequel to 2020 sonic the
hedgehog today we also know who will be
dubbing the skittish red aquina and it's
none other than the suicide squad star
idris alba via instagram alba shared a
picture of his character's clenched fist
putting an end to all speculation about
a possible casting of jason mamoa the
second sonic part follows on directly
from its forerunner and begins in the
tranquil life of sonic and his two
friends tom and maddie the letter taking
a little vacation leaving their beloved
blue hedgehog to take care of the house
but problems aren't long in coming dr
robotnik who has been exiled to a
mushroom planet sets out in search of an
overpowering emerald together with
knuckles whom he has manipulated in his
favor this emerald is capable of wiping
out entire civilizations given that
sonic would hardly stand a chance
against this evil plot all by himself he
gets support from tails who was teased
during the end credits of the first part
fans will have to wait a while before
sonic the hedgehog 2 however as it is
not scheduled to be released before
april 8th 2022
josh trang science fiction film
chronicle was released almost nine years
ago the story about the introverted
henry who later developed super powers
managed to inspire some viewers even
though the reviews were not overly
positive every now and then fans asked
frank about a sequel but he made a
statement about it last year affirming
that he would not make a second part
producer john davis seems to have a
different view of things not having
written off the project yet in an
interview with forbes the producer
talked about having a female protagonist
as to focus this time around telling her
own superpower story the story is to be
said about 10 years after the first part
sounds pretty good right but variety
reporter adam b vary considers the
anticipation for part 2 to be a bit too
hasty apparently there's little progress
from idea to production and if anything
it is a very early stage of development
so barry tried to get in touch with john
davis the latter however just put him
off as he could not comment on the
current state of affairs so chronicle 2
isn't quite as certain as one might
think at first and in any case we'll
have to be patient for a couple of years
[Music]